i'm pregnant
what yeah but i thought we were we were
careful
me too first of all i don't even think i
should be nice to you right now
come on come on you come on
i'm a good guy oh see
this is that is my first question is
lawrence a good guy
or is he that guy and when i say that
guy
every woman in america knows what i mean
by that guy
i think lawrence is a good guy
i do i really believe that i think uh
lawrence has made some bad decisions and
you know
the those those uh those seeds have now
grown
into full grown trees
and the fruit is here yes i mean the
fruit is coming
the fruit is it is harvest time okay
here's the thing
i think i i do think lawrence is a good
guy i think um
he truly has made some bad decisions um
what's interesting is i think for this
season i think lawrence
has been more thoughtful about his
decision-making process
i think he has realized that he has
made decisions in the past that he
didn't even think about the
repercussions of didn't think about how
it would affect other people and i think
now he's thought about that more
and i think you know somewhere between
episode four
clearly uh and episode
uh eight i think he obviously saw you
know candola
somewhere along the way and uh one or
two things happened
and he made a decision that you know
it's now coming back to to be a part of
his life forever
it's just too much it's really too much
can we talk about
the nicknames for canola oh my gosh
i'm gonna go through them actually
because i sent the text message i just
i actually sent the text questions to a
friend of mine yesterday and i was like
last night and i was like have you read
through these like this is crazy people
are crazy
i just saw on your instagram you post
one they are calling that girl
coronavirus i can't coronavirus
canola oil condensed milk cambodia
concentration no hesitation condolences
is my favorite condolences
why are we like this jay why are we like
this
the internet never loses the the
imagination
what i love is how people
it doesn't belong to us you know what i
mean i think
we get to be in this bubble and we get
to make this show
and we laugh and we have fun and we
think it's great but at the end of the
day
we realize that like we are
creating something as all artists do
that then go out to the world and that
that art now belongs to the world
and what i love so much about this show
is that our audience our culture our
fans
they take it you're good
condola came over last night
she needed to talk
okay about what when you read the script
that you have to tell her that condola
is pregnant like
how did you digest that so i didn't read
that script until a table read
usually we get the scripts the night
before a table read and
because i was prepping to direct my
episode
uh i had prep work that i had to do as a
director the next day and i had to act
the next day
on episode nine so i actually didn't
read the tin
until we did the table read uh
and we were on location uh
amy gravett who's the head of comedy was
there casey blows who's the head of hbo
was there i mean it was full it's our
last table read it's
70 80 people in this room and i remember
reading that scene and candola's saying
i'm pregnant
and i didn't jay could not say lawrence
is lying
because i was like
the whole room looks at me waiting for
me to save my life but i'm so
shocked that this is what she's saying i
just i will never forget that and casey
and amy natasha always like some people
from hbo are all across from me looking
at me
like what is happening right like my
mind
exploded like all over the room
i couldn't i couldn't believe it the way
you've set the table for season five
like i don't even know
how you approach it i mean okay lawrence
is going to be a dad you're a new dad so
do you actually
are you looking forward to seeing how he
navigates this world and bringing maybe
some of your real world stuff into the
in into the fold when i read this
episode
after the table read uh i pulled isa to
the side and i was like oh so you go
i'm a dad when i'm not at work and i'm a
dad when i'm at work now so i'm just i'm
on dad duty
24 hours a day basically is what you're
saying i got it i can't get no dad days
off
um you know i i don't know it'll be
interesting i think
you know i think obviously lawrence and
candola have to figure out how they're
going to
raise this child how their how that
relationship how they're going to
co-parent right and how they're going to
how they're going to go through that um
so i think that's going to be
interesting
you know i i do kind of laugh though at
like lauren's changing a diaper i laugh
at him
getting up in the middle of the night to
feed a baby i laugh at you know
at him not knowing how to entertain a
baby and keep a baby happy and so he's
doing all these crazy things i do
i do kind of laugh at those moments and
then also wonder what those moments look
like if
him and issa are still together what
those moments look like
with isso sitting next to him i think is
even
more like what how does that happen like
you know what i mean what are they both
thinking how do they go through all that
and now that we look back i think oh
they were setting the table for us when
lawrence was like kind of weirded out
about tiffany and derek's baby like
looking like what's going on here
like i'm like they were setting the
freaking table for us the whole time
yeah our writers are so good you know
and it's one of those things where you
what i again what i love about our fans
about our community uh is
they will take any single thing in an
episode
and create a conspiracy out of anything
and the one thing
that was right in front of everybody's
face
nobody saw it and that was lawrence not
being able to pick up a baby
and him being afraid to pick up a bit
like that one little thing
was one of those things where it's like
our our writers do a really amazing job
of like
you know they do a little bit of
foreshadowing and they drop these
breadcrumbs along the way and it's just
what
people pick up on so many different
things and that is definitely one of
those moments where it's like oh now
lawrence is actually going to experience
a poop vlog for himself
you know when he was laughing about it
exactly four episodes today
this is just a lot
i know okay we're still processing
everything i
i just had to tell you so this means
you're getting back with her no
no i told you i want to be with you but
you're having a baby with someone else
but i didn't plan this
i don't i don't want this to happen
i know okay going into season five is it
okay
for us fans to still root for lawrence
and issa
or should we protect our hearts and just
move it on
move along it is one of our great love
stories i do believe that
yeah i i do actually believe that i you
know i i
i hope they make it work i i hope people
don't give up on them because of this
because i think
love just in general is a bigger thing
than that
and something that like you know
everything is about how you handle it in
the conversations and being honest and
vulnerable with each other so i hope
that we get to
people will at least give them that
benefit of doubt and let them get there
and let them figure out what is best for
them i'm glad you came
i'm glad you called i blame molly for
everything this season just so you know
especially
for not figuring out what happened to
latoya because we are about to get the
answer
andrew was about to watch it and we were
about to see and then she
has to mess it up she messed it up once
again
it'll be interesting to see what happens
in season five but i just think she
doesn't realize
how giving andrew actually is for her
and by his giving which he probably is
given too much
uh uh she believes that that is
fair that is normal that is she doesn't
understand when things are off in their
relationship because she doesn't realize
how far he's skewed to another side of
giving to ben to what she wants
um and you know one of those things is
messing up looking for latoya
molly will find a way to mess up
something that's just
that's who she is
you